Donald Trump abruptly rage quit his own
press briefing yesterday after a
historically embarrassing implosion even
by Trump's own standards I've
essentially stopped covering the Press
briefings and the round tables and the
propaganda events on the podcast and the
broadcast show because they're just
trash I mean they they're simply
disinformation there's no news they are
worthless at communicating policy in any
significant way they've also been going
on a lot less frequently ever since
Trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach to treat coronavirus but
yesterday Trump scheduled one and it is
really worth telling you what happened
I'm going to skip right to the questions
part the presentation I can sum up as
we're the best on testing and the Envy
of the world uh with that out of the way
let's get to the questions we're going
to start with the build up about
obamigate we'll go to the climax where
Trump tells an Asian reporter to ask
China and then the day new mom where
Trump abruptly walks off Furious that a
CNN reporter tried to ask a question so
we'll start with Philip Rucker Philip is
White House bureau chief at the
Washington Post also wrote a book that
very much triggered Donald Trump called
the very stable genius Rucker is really
good at framing questions in a way that
directly exposed Trump's non-answers
Trump's been tweeting about so-called
Obama gate Trump tweeted it in all caps
with no explanation over the weekend
also claiming that the Obama
Administration and Obama himself
committed the biggest political crime in
American history here is Philip Rucker
expertly asking Trump which crime did
Barack Obama commit what law did he
break Trump glitches freezes and simply
repeats Obamacare Obama gate is the
crime take a look Mr President in one of
your Mother's Day tweets you appear to
accuse President Obama of the biggest
political crime in American history by
far are those were your words what crime
exactly are you accusing President Obama
of committing and do you believe the
justice department should prosecute him
uh obamigate it's been going on for a
long time it's been going on from before
I even got elected and it's a disgrace
that it happened and if you look at
what's gone on and if you look at now
all of this information that's being
released and from what I understand
that's only the beginning some terrible
things happened and it should never be
allowed to happen on our country again
Obama gate is the crime my friends now
Philip Rucker tries to follow up of
course now I looked at the U.S code of
law I couldn't find Obama gate as a
crime because it doesn't exist Trump has
no idea what he's talking about here's
the follow-up from Philip Rucker and
you'll be seeing what's going on over
the next over the coming weeks but and I
wish you'd write honestly about it but
unfortunately you choose not to do so
yeah John please what is the crime
exactly you know what the crime is the
crime is very obvious to everybody all
you have to do is read the newspapers
except yours uh John please yeah Mr
President this is a child ladies and
gentlemen this is a child so next let's
go to CBS news report
friend of the show
also extremely proficient at getting
Trump to blow his stack she asks why are
you always bragging about testing like
why whether it's true or not why is this
a competition when people are dying
people continue to die and Trump doesn't
like it he flips out and says why don't
you go ask that question to China
uh yeah go ahead please
said many times that the U.S is doing
far better than any other country when
it comes to testing yes why does that
matter why is this a global competition
to you if everyday Americans are still
losing their lives and we're still
seeing more cases every day well they're
losing their lives everywhere in the
world and maybe that's a question you
should ask China
don't ask me ask China that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very unusual answer yes behind
you please so this already makes no
sense before we even get to the Asian
component of it the question was why is
this a competition on testing while
people died he says go ask China ask
them what I don't hear the Chinese
president saying we have the most and
best tests or we've defeated the
invisible Scourge but then it gets
really wild when wejia Jang who is Asian
says why are you asking me to go talk to
China why why me sir why are you saying
that to me specifically I'm telling you
I'm not saying it specifically to
anybody I'm saying it to anybody that
would ask a nasty question please go
ahead why does it matter okay uh anybody
else so is this something about weijia
Jang being Asian American I don't know
with Trump you never know but it's all
just wacky it's cartoonish it's a comedy
of errors and this really has Trump
riled for the last bit of it the last
pillar of the three-headed monster for
Trump or the equivalent of Trump's
Kryptonite when being asked questions is
made up of Philip Rucker weijiya Jang
and lastly CNN's Caitlin Collins she
gets up to ask a question Trump called
on her right before weijiya jang's
follow-up I guess she didn't react
quickly Enough by allowing weijiya to
follow up and Trump rage quits and walks
out of the room or back into the White
House better said okay uh anybody else
please go ahead in the back please
I did and you didn't respond and now I'm
calling on sorry the young lady in the
back please I just want to let my
colleague ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much appreciate it thank you very
much I can't tell if at the end there
you hear someone say what the or if
that's something else
but what a moment what what an implosion
and this is why he's been cutting the
briefings because they're an
increasingly embarrassing disaster
imagine any other president Republican
or Democrat rage quitting after acting
this childishly so the Ouija Jang part
the Caitlyn Collins part these are more
about Trump's wacky Behavior he's
clearly very afraid of Caitlyn Collins
asking questions okay the really crucial
part here is Trump claiming Obama
perpetrated a crime presidents accusing
former presidents of crimes is a big
deal being asked what crime was
committed is logical and being unable to
say this is what the crime was is
particularly problematic now you may
surmise that there's no evidence that
Obama committed a crime that Donald
Trump is trying to accuse him of trump
is clearly desperate to take attention
off of the virus and instead go after
Obama for something anything and we've
got to watch this very closely because
we've seen Trump's justice department
say they're not going to prosecute a guy
who pleaded guilty Michael Flynn they
are now emboldened and they're liable to
really be out there with this Obama
crime stuff so we'll keep following it
including on our Instagram account make
sure you are following the David packman
show on Instagram at davidpackman show
and while you're there with peace and
love follow me on Instagram as well I am
david.pakman on Instagram
I've got something really cool today the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to davidpackman.com skill will get a
premium membership to skillshare for two
months for free skillshare is the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine everything's taught by experts
the classes get split up into bite-sized
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to
davidpackman.com skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video